okay so House of the Dragon episode 7
set up the seeds of war that episode 8
seems to be delivering on having read
The Source material I know there's some
big things coming and we're gonna be
breaking it all down in this video we'll
play the teaser in just a bit but it's
important to bear in mind that this has
another major time Jump in it that's
likely going to take us to the air 129
AC this is a massive point in the Fire
and Blood storyline in which a major
character dies so if you don't want any
spoilers then I suggest you turn off now
please hit the Thumbs Up Button if you
enjoy the video and make sure you
subscribe for breakdowns on the show
every week without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
trailer
as hand I speak with the king's voice on
this
and all other matters
tomorrow the high Towers land there
but those vipers rule in my father's
name
[Music]
's Landing then
the grave wounded back in Step Stones
who will take the Driftwood Throne the
crown cannot stand strong at the house
of the Dragon remains divided
this is a matter of blood not ambition
this is a trap nephews
threat of War lose
[Music]
okay so if we're right about this being
129 AC that would mean that we've had an
almost 10-year time Jam to the air of
viserys's death though his voiceover
appears in the teas up he's likely
Gravely ill at this point and this
explains why Otto Hightower is doing the
talking for him
Otto obviously has his own goals in mind
and thus it's impossible to even say if
what he's saying is what viserys wants
he says that he's the king's voice and
that he speaks on what he wants and all
other matters what other wants though is
his grandchild egging on the throne and
he'll do this at all costs in the book
this pushed Damon and runira Away who
ended up going to Dragonstone in order
to escape the kingdom I'll talk about
how this is a big mistake later on in
the video but it's all a play by Otto
who now rules the realm this is shown by
the fact that he stands in front of the
throne and her points even looks like
he's sat in it though it was coming for
the hand to do this this is definitely
symbolizing that he's now in charge of
the realm it'll be interesting to see if
he gets cut or not and if he doesn't and
it might indicate that the high Towers
aren't charge in the eyes of the throne
elsewhere we see that Alison is now in
viserys's seat on the council showing
that she's taken over it all now this
could be during one of two moments which
are brought up in the source material
the bug discusses how viserys started
hate ruling and all the issues that came
with the air because of this he stopped
going to the throne room and rarely
attended the court instead he plays
people in the sea too would seemingly do
his bidding for him but all they were
really after was taking over the kingdom
his personal maester also died during
these years and there was an effort on
both Ranier and Alison's part to try and
appoint their own however it was the
Citadel who ended up choosing but it
still shows how things have devolved in
them trying to pack everything with
their own people now the shot with
Alison may also be after viserys's death
due to her sitting in the main seat in
the mid-season trailer there's also a
shot where she stands by a window while
sucking upset a teaser also has a crown
on its own placed upon a pillow ending
that he's now in fact gone in the book
both runyo and Damon went to dragon's
Stone and thus when viz died Alison
ended up deciding not to send a raven to
her so that she could put her plan into
play she took over the council so that
they could quickly announce egg on II as
the king and all this happened while
srinero was giving birth this also shot
in the trailer with someone in bed and
now this could be callus and rhainees I
think it's actually viserys with
rhaenyra going to visit him huge had to
think story for pointing out of the
window pattern here can be seen at other
points in the mid-season trailer when
raniera stands in front of it it's going
to be interesting to see what option
they take with viserys's death as one
account in the book says that he died
naturally in his sleep however the other
says that Alison murdered him and
earlier in the season there was
suspicion from lanor and runira that she
might end up poisoning him anyway
raniera's baby comes out stillborn and
it's believed to have had a dragon's
tail the birth brought rhaenyra a lot of
pain and she said that Alison not only
killed her child but that she also took
the throne from her in one Fell Swoop we
also get a shot of the family and aegon
looks like he's gonna be a right little
in this trailer doesn't he as you can
tell they've all been aged up and this
time he's going to be played by Tom
Glenn Carney who you might recognize
from Dunkirk Eamonn is also there too
and he's spotting a badass eye patch and
makes him look like liquid snake and big
boss combined there's also Helena and
it's likely that she's gonna be married
to aegon at this point she married when
she was 13 and the pair ended up having
twins there was one girl and also one
boy who had six fingers and toes due to
them being inbred like subway fillings
however this trailer also has a big
focus on baymund and with this episode
being titled lord of the tides I think
it's gonna predominantly center around
him just when you thought the entire
thing with the heirs was complicated
enough it's about to come out even worse
Elena was of course killed by Vega and
Leno faked his own death making it seem
like both of corliss's children are now
dead and buried because of this both The
Heirs of drift Mark are no longer there
to inherit the throne and this Raymond
wants to be announced as the next in
line in the book this causes a lot of
issues because running error of course
has two children who should be The Heirs
because of the line of succession Jace
will get their own Throne whereas
lucaris will inherit driftmark this will
give them complete rule of both the land
and sea and due to many thinking they're
not legitimate they get contested a lot
they're supposed to be Lionel's kids
even though everyone knows the truth we
all know and last week rainis brought
this up and she wanted callers to
appoint Raina and Baylor as the air but
Corliss wasn't having any of it he said
that names meant more than blood and
thus the strongs are still seen as The
Heirs to drift Mark just like how
viserys wouldn't see the truth he
refuses to as well and this causes
issues in both of the kingdoms of aiming
gets pretty annoyed by this and he
publicly announces that the strongs are
bastards at the start of the trailer we
see a royal ship going to King's Landing
which may be him but I think it's more
likely just raniera and Damon they talk
about returning to the kingdom in the
teaser to Take Back Control I think it's
more likely a shot of them the Sails are
black and there's also the Royal chamber
that appears in the Royal bow with them
on board Rainier talks about how the
high Towers have struck the first blow
which likely calls back to last week
when Alison cut her hand this was seen
as first blood but technically Eamonn
was in the receiving end of it due to
losing his eye anyway calling the
Strong's bastard is a big No-No and as
we saw last week this caused a lot of
issues with aemond viserys now classes
it as high treason and he said that
anyone who said this was the case would
have their tongues cut out this doesn't
happen with Raymond and instead things
escalate quickly with runira turning it
up to 11. he sends Damon to get him and
he beheads him before feeding his body
to Cyrax yikes now this happens during
126 AC so it's possible that the time
Jump may go to this point rather than
129 with them just combining events from
The Heirs I don't know exactly what
order they'll place these events in but
we also get another bathroom during this
time as renura plans to Wed her kids to
Damon's I'm guessing this will happen
when first disputes out of The Heirs and
thus to quickly counter that ranera will
form the wedding Alliance so that they
get it either way now we might also get
the tongue cutting scene that we've
talked about in the last two breakdowns
there were some of Raymond's family that
were disgusted by the death of their
cousin and they went directly to viserys
to plea to him to realize the strongs
were bastards but Sarah sat and listened
to them listing all the evidence without
saying a word and then when they were
done he ordered to have their tongues
removed I think it's probably too
similar to the scene with Laris to do
this but I thought I'd just bring it up
in case I end up doing it again now
there's also a big banquet after the
death of Raymond in which viserys tries
to unite the houses one more time the
buck talks about how they wore their
opposite sides colors in a show good
faith and by this I mean ranero wears
green whilst Alison wears red and black
a compliment each other throughout and
it makes viserys really happy so happy
for the guy the book even talks about
how Damon salutes Otto and the pair have
of course hated each other since episode
1 but it's all fine now we can all relax
It's Over Now viserys ends up going to
bed and though they were trying to be
civil it didn't last long Eamonn ends up
toasting the family and he refers to his
nephews as the strongest boys that he's
ever seen what mate did he did he just
we'll let that slide though we're trying
to keep the peace but then then amen
follow this by saying let us train our
cups to these three strong boys it all
kicked off after this which I think you
could see in the teaser and this
probably happens right after this moment
the Rel never recovers and I think this
is when raniero will pack her bags and
finally leave she probably goes to see
her father one last time before he dies
which is likely the Bad scene that we
get in the teaser it is possible that
Raymond may even be working with the
high towers as we see him alongside
their soldiers at one point they had the
green flags in house sigil so Otto and
Allison may have brought him in to help
oust the strongs now it's also very
likely that Ray and Damon will have
their own children during this time to
make things even more confusing they're
called aegon invisary Paris Alison takes
The Airgun one as a slide to hear which
the book notes that it definitely was
because it talks about how from that
point onwards that the child will be
called egg and the younger whilst the
older one will be called egg on the
Elder The Source material goes into
haranira never really lost her baby
weight and that she ended up becoming
fat and almost grotesque I don't think
they're gonna go this rude but it is
important to bear in mind how she went
from the Realms to lie to this after all
the stress of being the air had on her
with Alison it talks about how Rey grew
jealous of her because she kept her slim
figure and didn't seem to carry the
weight at all a day [ __ ] now the
details you might miss in the teaser are
that Alison is wearing a faith of the
seven necklace she wasn't wearing this
in the last episode and is probably now
leaned into the religion heavily we also
get a shot of this symbol in the small
Council window the faith of the seven is
the most dominant religion in the realm
and if she can get this behind her as
well she'll be even more powerful Alison
and her family are also joined by
everyone's everyone's favorite
characters these days sir Kristen Cole
the bastard her child Darren isn't there
and I don't know if he's going to be in
the series or not as he should be born
by now he spent most of his youth in Old
Town so they might just be skipping out
on him so things don't get even more
complicated there's also a quick shot of
what I'm guessing is Damon going to
mazaria she now runs most of the
underworld and the cloak is similar to
what Damon has won in the past he'll
likely try and get her to work with them
but as we've seen she's happy playing
both sides either way that's the trailer
and I can't wait to watch the next
episode The Series has been getting
better and better and I think this one
is gonna be a big one let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and also
if we missed anything be sure to point
it out for any competition right now and
giving away three copies of dollar and
thunder on the 15th of October and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the teaser who picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on the
screen right now now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers young emails to watch make sure
you check out our breakdown of episode 7
in which we go over all the ins and outs
of the entry that'll be linked on the
screen right now so head over there and
thanks for singing through the video by
the way I've been poor I'll see you next
time take care peace